and good afternoon we do start tonight
with a sad update to a story that we've
been following since last week
alexander that german shepherd that was
stabbed several times
has now died after two attempted
life-saving surgeries
thanks for joining us here at five i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
you'll remember the animal foundation
stepped in to care for alexander orco
mana joins us now live from durango in
charleston
with an update on this case orca
well brian and denise we've learned from
metro police that the stabbing happened
on thursday
at one of the homes here on pavia street
which again is near
charleston and durango investigators say
someone stabbed a dog named alexander
and a man who lived there and then ran
off according to a post on the animal
foundation's facebook page
alexander did not make it because his
injuries were too severe
the german shepherd suffered from
multiple stab wounds to his side
neck and legs one was so deep his spleen
and part of his intestine
were removed the animal foundation
started caring for alexander on friday
the shelter had been collecting
donations to help alexander
and they say any additional money is
going directly to their care fund which
helps other injured animals
the animal foundation is calling
alexander a hero and say their hearts go
out to his owners during this difficult
time
and back out here live metro police tell
us the injuries to the man
who was stabbed during the attack are
non-life-threatening investigators add
that this is an open case
and they are still searching for the
suspect reporting live in las vegas
tonight orgomana 8 news now